in one of the nation's hit hardest by
covid 19 in europe
people observed social distancing as
they waited for their turn to be tested
cases in belgium have reached close to
10 000 a day
prompting the health minister to warn of
an impending tsunami unless things are
brought under control
in an effort to stem the spread of the
virus bars and restaurants have been
ordered to close
and people to limit social contact
outside of their households
to one person for the next month we
think it's not
the good or the right solution because
now what will happen probably is that a
lot of people they will make parties
at their home without any restrictions
about safety so that will probably
even higher the rates to the future
the start of the week also brought
strict controls back to the italian city
at the heart of the nation's worst
cavite 19 outbreak
earlier this year residents in milan
and across the country facing limits on
social contacts
and hundreds queuing at free testing
centers
people worried not just about their
health but their jobs and the economy
more than about the virus now we will
have the normal seasonal flu as well
i'm much more worried about the economic
situation that we're living in now
there could be a danger of catching the
disease we don't know how it will go
i hope that it will not grow as much as
the other countries how we've seen in
france
england and germany because they are
worse off than us
in france the police have been enforcing
a curfew introduced
over the weekend as the world health
organization revealed
europe had hit a record number of cases
in the last week
president macron's wife brigitte is
self-isolating after contact with
someone
who tested positive for kovid poland has
announced the national stadium in warsaw
will be converted into a vast field
hospital
the health minister warning there could
be 20 000
cases a day by next week
countries and healthcare systems across
europe are struggling to cope
and there's no certainty new
restrictions will bring kovid
19 under control michelle clifford sky
news